>> TASSMUND: Hi there. Matt Tassmund, we're
from iRevolution. I'm going to show you our
product WaveLook today. So, our goal at iRevolution
is to revolutionize communication and we believe
Wave revolutionized communication. We've been
working with Wave right from the start. Our
focus has been the enterprise, specifically
Microsoft Outlook and Exchange. All of us
working the enterprise, we all dealt with
a lot of e-mail. We all dealt with shuffling
data from Skype to Excel to, you know, Outlook
to PowerPoint and back. And we felt Wave was
a better way and we've working on it right
from the start. So I'm going to show you three
things today. The first thing is our Outlook
integration. So we have a product, WaveLook
for Outlook. It's available today. You can
download it from our website at wavelook.com,
click on the nice download button, it's in
beta. So let's take a look here. I have Outlook
running. WaveLook for Outlook lets you add
your WaveLook account into--your Wave account
into Outlook. You can add it right into your
inbox. So here are my matttassmund@gmail.com
Waves, sorry, e-mails in the same inbox with
my matttassmund@gmail.com Waves. So that's
something that was important--that's something
that was important to us because we were tired
of having to have Gmail in one browser tab
and Wave running in another browser tab, so
we integrated right into your inbox. The other
option we have is you can actually have a
separate .pst file here. This is a WaveX we
test at Googlewave.com that is a separate
.pst that syncs directly to that .pst. So
this is Outlook with two users' accounts from
Wave integrated into the same histories. So
we basically built our own editor. We started
from scratch. This is all in C# because Outlook,
you have to do everything in C#. And so, for
example, here is our rich text editor. This
is our standard test Wave. I can come in here.
Actually, there's one of our guys editing.
Right here, I can come in. I can edit it at
the same time. It's just a standard Wave editor
that we built from scratch. What's interesting
is we also got draft edit working, so I can
go into draft mode. Actually, notice that
Kevin's actually in live mode and so he is
still is typing while I'm in draft mode and
then when I'm ready to go, I can hit set.
So we modeled this based on how e-mail works,
how the enterprise works, how people that
use Outlook works and we followed--that's
the model we worked on. We also have playback
and we have--so here's playback, for example.
So it kind of goes through and shows you all
the deltas and you can go back and forward
in time. We have inline comments working,
replies, every--I mean, pretty much all Wave
functionality including private replies. So
that was our first product that we released.
It's WaveLook for Outlook. This was released
back in July and we've seen adoption. And
around the same time, we started working on
our own Wave server. So, I'm going to show
you that next. Actually, one last thing, so
here is the same Wave in two different accounts.
So this is matttassmund@gmail.com. There's
a WaveX we test at gmail.com and it works
even inside Outlook where, as I type stuff,
it shows up on the other side. This is the
standard Wave and every loves but running
inside the Outlook--running inside the Outlook
and Exchange and the reason is that half the
enterprise, I think about 500 million accounts,
use Outlook and Exchange, so that's what we're
targeting. The next thing that we started
working on was our own Wave server. So, we
got that. We've been working on it for months
and we finally have it working. And so, let
me show you what that is. So here, like I
said, it's all C#. That's [INDISTINCT] studio
and that's our server running. I'm going to
go to local host. And we actually have this
running in the cloud and also something you
can download and install on premises. So I'm
going to login with my wavelook@wavelook account,
and I login. Now, so we built the server and
we needed something to make sure our server
worked. So what we did is we got the existing
Google web client running against our server
and it really helped because it helped us
rally in a lot of the things that we were
doing wrong, but basically because of that,
you can now go in here and you can edit Waves
and do all that fun stuff. So that's our server
that we're running. We'll be switching to
the Wave in the Box web client, I guess, at
some point, although it's in Java and all
of this is in C#, so we'll have to figure
out something there. And then around the time
that the Wave project got canceled, we worked
on the server and we decided to build a migration
tool because we had a lot of data in Wave
and we wanted to make sure it was preserved.
But what was important to us was we didn't
want the forking to happen, where once we
migrate now, if I have some people who haven't
migrated, if they make changes to the one
on Google Wave then, you know, I loose them
because I've already forked. So what we ended
up doing was we ended up creating--so let
me open up our other build of the server--we
ended up creating a migration for Google Wave
but with two-way sync. And what that means
is--so let me login--what that means is I
log in with my Gmail account or my Gmail credentials
or any Wave account, any Google Wave account
credentials--that's Gmail, and this is my
actual Wave--and I hit migrate. And now, eventually,
this is--these are my actual waves from Google
Wave running on our server. Any changes I
make are actually applied first on our server
but we treat the Google Wave server as the
master. So--and basically that allows us to
keep running in a two-way sync with Google
Wave servers until they go offline, at which
point this server will become the master for
the Wave. But the advantage of that is if
I log in to my Wave account, I can--so this
is the same Wave that has been migrated; Google
Wave on the right, our sever running on the
left, but I can edit the same Wave on our
servers. And we first OT it and store it on
our server, send it to Google Wave and then
based on what happens, we go back.
>> Which protocol do we use to talk to Google
Wave?
>>TASSMUND: So we started working on this
a long time ago and there was no protocol,
so we reverse engineered the ACTP protocols
that the client--and use it right now. So
they're--so that's what we're using.
>> That client, are you proxying the Google
client and then...?
>>TASSMUND: No. So what we actually have working
is two-way sync. So any change that comes
through, we first write it to our server and
then send it out to Google.
>> Did that client that you--that's the GWT
client that you [INDISTINCT]?
>>TASSMUND: Oh yes, it's just that we took
the JS files. It's all obfuscated.
>> Right, yeah.
>>TASSMUND: And we're hosting them on our
server.
>> Yeah, and then?
>>TASSMUND: But then it's talking back to
our server.
>>Right. Okay.
>>TASMUND: And so those are the--that's what
we've been working on, the Outlook for the
enterprise and then our own server and then
migration because we felt that all of us,
you know, we want people to migrate, but if
you migrate and you can't talk to the people
again that you were talking to before, then
you kind of have this forking issue. And so,
this is our solution at solving that. That's
kind of what we're working on. And yeah, so
any questions? You know, you can download
WaveLook today. We're doing a quick survey
on Wave usage, so we'll appreciate it if people
could sign up. And then also, you know, our
server and--will be available soon, so if
you guys can--if you want to--if you want
to try it out, you can sign up for that there.
>> All right, this thing is very cool.
>> TASSMUND: Oh, thanks.
>> Does the Wave server support [INDISTINCT]?
>> TASSMUND: That's something we're working
on. It doesn't support it yet, but that's
what we're working on. It does support persistent.
So, for example, I could have two people--and
it's kind of interesting. We came up with
our own persistent system and then we saw
the file-base system. It was, like, almost
exactly the same because we have the same
thing where--I think our only differences
are we store a file for a Wave and then a
folder for Wave or something like that, but
it was very similar when we saw the spec you
put out. Someone else had a question? Okay.
Okay. Yeah. If you have any other questions,
I'll be around and, you know, just let me
know.
>> I do have a question though. So the current
integration in Outlook, what server agent
is that right now?
>> TASSMUND: It works with the Google Wave
server or our servers, either one.
>> So the server is something that integrates
with Exchange or is something that has to
be installed?
>>TASSMUND: So the server, if you want, can
integrate it with Exchange so we can get contacts
directly. And then from a web client perspective,
we're going to do--be doing an Exchange integration
that integrates directly into the Outlook
web client. So that would be a direct integration
into Exchange. So, it's up to you. If you
want contacts and, you know, the admin and
the client access, then you would integrate
into Exchange and you would be able to use
the Windows domain credentials.
>> What is the--when the server integrates
with Exchange, what kind of integration do
you use?
>>TASSMUND: Right now, it's just SSL or HTTP
because our sever exposes the same authentication
as the Google Wave server does, that we basically
got it working as Google Wave server and then
made our server do the same thing.
>> So the integration with Outlook, if I want
Outlook, then I can [INDISTINCT] using the
password in order to get at my Waves?
>> TASSMUND: Yes. So the first time you have
to--for now, you have to go in and you have
to add an account and we just ask you for
your credentials. But once we have the Exchange
integration fully completed, then you'll actually
just use your Exchange credentials, as long
as you have our server running with the same
credentials.
>> Do you make the Exchange with the principal
Windows [INDISTINCT] server?
>>TASSMUND: No, no. So we got it working as
a Google Wave server and then built our server
to match the Google Wave server, which is
why the same client can talk to either server.
Okay, well, thank you very much. Let me know
if you have any questions. We'll be around.
change integration fully completed, then you'll
actually just use your Exchange credentials,
as long as you have our server running with
the same credentials.
>> Do you make the Exchange with the principal
Windows [INDISTINCT] server?
>>TASSMUND: No, no. So we got it working as
a Google W